we have helded 500 plus Brands who are
actively using our uh platform day in
and day out like including companies
like General Mills Yokohama Honda PWC
and Amcor so such kind of large
companies use our platform to manage
their International shipments and uh now
domestic shipments as well we are we
have offices in New Jersey Singapore and
India and we are operating uh in more
than 35 countries helping customers in
more than 35 countries to manage their
uh manage their shipments our team is
are more than more than 150 people
strong and we we don't want to increase
the team a lot but using these team
members only with the help of these team
members only we are able to uh grow to
such a scale and help so many customers
because we are building a scalable uh
solution to the
[Music]
problem gotam Prem Jane welcome to 20
minute leaders thank you so much for
being with me how are are you I'm doing
great Michael thank you and it's a
pleasure to be here thank you so much
for joining me I'm really excited to
dive into your own entrepreneurial
Journey H that of also go Comet and
talking a little bit about the way that
you're H taking a a really interesting
problem that I I find very interesting
in the logistics space and and air
transportation and and really making a
big dent in it and and your own
background also is is is super
interesting both from an entrepreneurial
perspective but also from an academic
perspective and so I'm I'm really
curious about that as well but tell me a
little bit about you know what you know
what what space we're even in so seven
years ago or so you're you're looking
into the space up from an
entrepreneurial side what what is the
problem that we're experiencing here
sure Michael um I when we actually
started go Comet we were not planning uh
to start a software company in this
space in fact we were doing a small site
business where we were buying goods from
China and drop shipping them in the US
so while we found that buying and
selling were easy because of alibaba.com
and amazon.com where we act
transportation of the goods from China
to the US was where like lot of our
energy lot of our time went uh we had to
reach out to multiple straight
forwarders websites and then wait for
the replies and be thinking we can track
like uh
$10 uh cab ride or $60 cab very easily
on our phones and we can do the same for
food but we cannot track a $100,000
worth of container so easily right we
thought that is that how this industry
operates we did a little bit we talked
to a lot of people we talked to a few
more people and we found that actually
even the largest companies operated on
emails and phone calls they did not have
a newator system which is like there for
everyone to use and we found that oh my
God like this is a huge huge problem and
this is a huge opportunity so we quit
our jobs at that time and we decided to
start po an incredible and now why is it
do you think that so you you're
discovering this big gap and this big
problem space you know what what led to
this opening so what were the different
market conditions or the advancements
which now led to this big vacuum that
you're filling in oh um shortly I can I
can share about that what we have
learned about this is that there are a
few departments so in 1980s the Erp
systs came right oras and scps they
started and uh then every company who's
who operates now has to have an Erp
system in 2000s the CRM systems came
right for customer management then hrms
systems came support support ticketing
systems came and now like most of the
Departments are there such that which
have a system every company who starts
they have to have a system for that
department however we thought we found
that Logistics was a space which was not
especially International Logistics it
was a space which was not considered to
be upgraded only the top few companies
like the Fortune 100 companies made
their own customer development software
but not this one I think one reason for
that is because it doesn't appear to us
uh in normal everyday lives right it's
not unless you are an Import and Export
industry it's not visible to us uh how
it impacts our daily lives more than 50
% of the goods that we use are either
like imported from other countries or
lot of goods are exported from every
country right so it touches a li but
it's a blackbox it's like invisible to
most of us and that is why I think the
innovation did not happen that's not the
case anymore now a lot of companies are
opening up they have uh they have
actually started looking for a system
when they started goard it was not the
case now they are actively looking for a
system uh which is supply chain
visibility system to help their
International
Logistics and so the impact obviously on
the on the consumer I think is uh is is
hugely important and and the impact on
the on these companies as well I guess
it's primarily fin Financial ER you know
less Financial costs for them and less
and and more
competitiveness oh it's both it's both
one of the B for example advantages uh
for for people who use go comet is that
they can give Amazon like updates to
their consigning to their end consigning
and it's hard to believe but it was not
possible before poom it or before a few
years ago so the companies they had to
track the shipments online and they had
to send manual updates even if they are
doing like 700 containers a month they
had to send manual upat to the customer
so if something doesn't reach on TI
someone picked up the phone and called
someone that where is my shipment they
can't find it online right and then they
ask some other person because generally
the call would go to the person who sold
them which is in sales team they would
not know of the shipment it will go to
another car and that's how the shipment
would be tracked instead like that's a
huge problem ideally it should be very
easy very easy world map where I can see
where all my shipments are when are they
going to arrive along with the expected
date so I can plan my inventory I can
plan my trucks according to the
shipments it should be very easy to see
and if any shipment is delayed I am not
concerned about the uh 500 shipments I'm
concerned about the 15 shipments which
have been because they can impact my
production schedule so it should be very
easy to see them on one place as
exception management and that's we
enable the and then who who in the who
is responsible for looking at this
visibility platform and have the
insights as to what's happening who what
what is sort of this figure like and
what is the responsibility in their
day-to-day sure so that is mostly the
VPS of supply chain or Ps of
international Logistics so they they are
the respons they are responsible that
everything happens on time and generally
their job is hard it's like day from
starting to the end it's unending Exel
and emails going about all their
shipments there is a lot of
documentation for customers which is
required there is trans coordination
required between the freight brokers
between The Shipping Lines the C the
custom uh uh house agents HS and uh
between the actual production of the
material so there's a lot ofation
required only when things go wrong do we
hear about them just like the Red Sea
crisis uh like it blocked the the SE
canal and the ships had to take a longer
route it increased The Plight prices or
not as the ships who had to go and take
a longer Road increase the air flight
prices because company started shipping
by air right and it and ultimately led
to blockage of a lot of ships and it
increased the rates in other regions
which were not gone just like from China
to Singapore those shipment SS were
increased because and they had nothing
to do with that se because they're in a
connected world right so this uh that's
their job to manage these shipments and
to ensure that it reaches on
time for the for the end customers to uh
to for the holiday season for the
regular work uh for getting things on
typ 100 that super fascinating why why
is this fascinating for you there's many
many interesting problems other why why
is this problem particularly interesting
for you in general so before go com
actually we had started the company
called plat uh we were in the third year
uh of our College we got inspired by
like alumni from uh my uh from from the
same College like VOD kosla Sund P they
are all uh and and we were always
thinking we should build a huge business
like them we should we if we get the
opportunity why we will take that uh
like with both hands so in fact it
started during the third year of college
and in that we started that uh again it
was in the real estate uh real estate
industry right it was a broker
Marketplace real estate agents
Marketplace used using technology to
help them connect to each other right
then housing.com acquired a company and
why this is important to us we are
finding even the real estate even
International Logistics both had unsexy
Industries both of them unx Industries
which a lot of people do not uh start
think to start a business in that's why
we think a huge gap remains in these
areas there are literally so many things
to solve you find just one good piece
and you solve that for the entire world
world and like the world will be better
for it and we will have created a huge
company uh in that uh process so that is
why we think that U uh to solve the to
get the actually go after this
opportunity of going after the HK scene
Industries yeah and I think safe to say
that we we're learning that these unsexy
industries those are where you both
probably have the most potential for
Innovation while also disrupting entire
business you know business models that
that are highly profitable are are there
interesting technological or engineering
related opportunities or challenges when
it comes to the auto to to the to the
platform you're building that that you
now you know from the engineering side
also excite you absolutely absolutely
that is actually we are using a lot of
AI uh in our platform right now for
example one of the key things is like
reading digitization of invoices right
so invoice Orin is a huge process there
is a process where companies need to
know the predictive ETA of their
shipments when is how can you predict
when my shipment will arrive there is a
lot of AI which is used to accurately
predict uh that where are thousands of
shipments currently what can be the
future potential issues at any of the
grass shipment ports or at uh any of
because or any schedule of the ship
ships right the vessels so this leads to
using The Cutting Edge latest um methods
of prediction and AI uh helps helps us
in uh giving the best value to our
customers so it when we started it was
just like basic GE BS what has led to
now increasing and better uh increasing
U you can say the state of the art
technology which we using in other
fields to predict do predictions in the
supply chain industry as well because
companies want that
visibility MH so
that just just to double down on the on
to double down on the pred on the
prediction side so what what what in
your in Your Vision what could the
prediction element actually Prov provide
from a business perspective so now
bridging from the predictive AI to the
the business impact H how big of an
impact can this actually be if if you
know done done right and and fully
implemented looking from a businesses
perspective they have to maintain a
certain days of production inventory
just in case something happens right
just in case a shipment is delayed so
they have to fill their warehouses with
unused inventory for uh for example 30
days of inventory right if you are able
to accurately predict when my shipments
are arriving then they are able to
accurately Place orders and plan their
inventory better this has helped many of
our customers to actually reduce the
number of inventory Days by up to like
40% right and this has a huge impact on
their you can you can understand that it
can have a huge impact on the working
capital it can have a huge impact uh on
on the people who are managing
this incredible tell me a little bit
about go Comet today as a as a company
as a solution a little bit about where
you
stand we have held 500 plus Brands who
are actively using our uh platform day
in and day out like including companies
like General Mills Yokohama Honda PWC
and amcore uh so such kind of large
companies use our platform to manage
their International Shipmates and uh now
domestic shipments as well we are we
have offices in New Jersey Singapore and
India and we are operating uh in more
than 35 countries helping customers in
more than 35 countries to manage their
uh manage their shipments are team is
are more than more than 150 people
strong and we we don't want to inrease
the team a lot but using these team
members only with the help of these team
members only we are able to uh grow to
such a scale and help so many customers
because we are building a scalable uh
solution to the
problem phenomenal and so take take me
to your vision you know five years on
the line work sure sure we see that uh
just like other departments just like
CRM just like uh there is Erp solution
that accounting softwares International
Logistics is also going to have a UB
goodus supply chain visibility platform
where every company who has to do import
and exports will be using a system to
manage their shipment that is not
apparrently not there when these see
that will happen when at least 80% of
the companies in the world have moved to
such a system at goov our vision is to
make that change happen give them the
opportunity give them a solution which
which can ease their lives St their cost
and transform an industry as a
whole amazing well I I I got on I I wish
you best of luck on this Mission I think
it's a it's a huge bold vision and I
think the disrupting existing Industries
is incredibly uh incredibly exciting
and uh and Innovative T take me a little
bit to your
entrepreneurial side so your own
experience as a now serial entrepreneur
building companies seeing the roller
coaster ride you know we're living in
some of the most tumultuous times from
the market from every perspective both
technological and business-wise what are
you what what are you what are you
experiencing yourself
here so Michael when we started goom in
that was just after a boom and a bust in
the Indian startup ecosystem 2015 was
like lot of companies had raised money
and then 2016 was where very few
companies were able to raise money I
knew at that time and that's that's a
key uh message that I generally share
with a lot of entrepreneurs is that
market ups and downs will come it's our
job as entrepreneurs to plan for them so
that we don't get swept away when those
markets up it again came couple of years
ago then the market was in Euphoria
everyone was in Euphoria people were
hiring Engineers like with crazy
salaries all around the world you
couldn't get your hands on a good
engineer at any time so me and my CTO we
spoke about it we uh thought that and
and based on our learnings from earlier
we said that no this is not the good
time to hire anyone any could uh any
senior leader of engineer in our company
so we also realized that it's a bubble
and it will burst in sometime six months
we waited for it and layoffs started
happening every company started laying
off there were lot of startups who sadly
had to close because they were not
getting any more funding and we we were
lucky to get a few good engineers at
that time who had like Clos their own
companies and who were like uh like
Min with us had a great culture and then
build that company the point is that
when everyone is hiring do the opposite
don't hire when everyone is laying off
then is the time to do most investing
but you don't see that in the current
home right when everyone was invest V is
used to give a lot of money now it's not
possible for any startup to get money
very easily however I believe this is
the best time for investment this is the
best time for investment because no one
is doing that this is the best typ of
marketing and for scaling up existing
companies with strong and limited right
so our lesson is that like just be uh
taking a step back it's very easy to get
involved in like get get very busy the
day today and not think of these big
things and then hoping that it will go
well it's not the right way then you
running a business you have to take that
market ups and downs will come another
lesson is that you how do you prepare
for such ups and downs is that your
business should be dependent on your
customer Leven it should not be
dependent solely on the Miss money uh
although M money has helped us and it we
have used it for growth always use the
BC money for growth but not for day
today operations DayDay operations
should be carried out with customers
money and that is where you can build a
company which is resilient and will not
not dependent on uh let's say the money
of people with VC because they it's not
their mistake as that the LPS who are
putting money in VCS correctly the
interest R are so high that they will
withdraw that money and they will put
that in other markets which have given
better returns right so vs can't put
more money but we can't be dependent on
such ups and downs which will come again
definitely seven years it will come
again and lot it cycle will start again
and what is it the thing you enjoyed
most on on your entrepreneurial Journey
so
far there was um in the initial when we
did not have any customers uh we were
actually uh we we were trying to find
out in 2016 that what a product should
be and can be one of the leading uh
pharmaceutical companies in India they
we just had a couple of like good
screens at that time and not not working
product so they gave us a two1 p to
prove our product right to prove our
product and uh we had to build the
product and provide provide value for
one of the largest export and import
businesses it's like super Monumental
task very tough to do that so what we
did for uh those two months was that
every day I used to go in the morning
with their first team member I gave them
the product to use gave them the screens
to use and saw them how they are using
it got their feedback came back with the
last team member of their day to back to
my co-founders who are like Tech
Geniuses and they can like they coded
throughout the night to get those
insights implemented and again in the
morning I used to show that go to the
customer again and show to their users
this is how you can use the product this
would go for two months daily and it it
it became like a for me like my
co-founders used to tease me and say
that uh like you join their office only
you are not coming to our office you
their office so that's that's the that
story stays with me because it got us
one of our very successful and very sell
very like great contracts and a huge
brand name with us which led
six out of 10 largest pharmaceutical
companies of India like working with us
um and now we don't serve only Pharma we
serve fmcg we serve Auto we serve
chemicals as well and yeah that product
is giving value to sort of like all
sorts of customers in all the industries
and it makes me extremely proud to see
that amazing well Tom I I really
appreciate your time and your energy and
your inspiration and your uh your
optimism it it really resonates through
through this uh conversation and I I am
excited to share this uh with everybody
H so best of luck with go Comet continue
doing amazing work in Supply chains and
and uh bringing uh new and Cutting Edge
technology and models to this um but
also thank you for the for the insights
on the general entrepreneurial journey
and and building resilient companies
that are adaptive and can sustain the
different H roller coasters so thank you
very very much for your time thank you
Michael it just great speaking to you
and hope it helps thank you
[Music]